[Music]
the humanity one rescue ship was still
in Port Wednesday but without its
passengers after a climb down by the
Italian government 250 people mostly
Africans were finally allowed to
disembark from the boat and a second
vessel the geo-barents after being
stranded in the Sicilian Port of Catania
since Saturday
until Tuesday the Italian government
said they were not vulnerable enough to
enter the country but late in the
evening they were unexpectedly allowed
to leave it's a victory for human rights
campaigners and the rescue ship's
captains who would refuse to sail away
with them on board it's in this case a
victory that we showed that the writers
on our side that we're not doing
something illegal and that this decree
which was brought against us was illegal
and that these actions in the last 14
days were not correct prime minister
Georgia Maloney came to power on a
promise to crack down hard on illegal
migration neither She nor any government
Minister has explained the reasons
behind the about turn but it's believed
internal and external pressure came to
bear we are in on the edge and I think
the government is moving on a very
complicated path respecting the EU not
accepting the EU the EU and at the same
time trying to do what what he was voted
for people aboard the humanity one has
started a hunger strike in a desperate
bid to be admitted to the country the
question now is Will the government
abandon its tough starts or approach it
in a different way
the Italian government's Hardline stand
may have kept its supporters happy but
in reality its Crackdown policy couldn't
work legally it's been widely criticized
for denying rights and compassion to
people who were simply seeking a safer
better life
these people were allowed into Sicily
some time ago they're learning Italian
in order to better assimilate into the
community those that have made the long
and dangerous journey to Italy are a
cross-section of Asylum Seekers refugees
and migrants but all have one thing in
common they want a better life
ibrahima is from Guinea his trip in a
small boat across the Mediterranean six
years ago was risky but not as dangerous
as some he now speaks excellent Italian
and is grateful to Italy but has
concerns more than one government some
of them have helped people like me who
have been here for a short time and the
current government doesn't help and
makes life difficult it's not right
a happy end for some but looking out at
the central Mediterranean where more
than 20 000 people have drowned making
the perilous Journey you wonder how many
more victims will the cruel Seas of
winter claim Tony bertley Al Jazeera
Catania Sicily